your character kimmy schmitt moves from
small-town rural area to the big city of
new york that's the same thing that you
did exactly yes there must be
similarities there there are some
similarities I'm I grew up in st. Louis
Missouri the the Midwest yeah go Rams
all of the time I think they're still in
st. Louis yeah you there was no
conviction behind it no it's like you
put that on a post-it go Rams all of the
time and I'll just put that up right
there
I said people weren't thinking she only
means every other day but yes the
Heartland
I moved from Missouri to New York and I
when I first moved to New York you know
it's it's I feel so much Jamie it's
intimidating I was intimidated when I
first went there it's scary yeah and uh
you know actually one thing I did when I
first went there who is um I said I took
up smoking for four days I I don't know
and this is the first time my mom is
hearing about this I don't smoke anymore
I don't but I I thought like well I'm
trying to figure out what I'm doing I'm
going to I don't know maybe this will
open up some new possibilities I'm not
sure and so I practiced smoking in my
apartment and my bedroom was like the
window was so close to the next door
think that like I would blow out and
like it would just hit the brick and
like bounce right back at me I don't I
was so scared that I couldn't extinguish
the cigarette yeah that would hold it
under the tap like to make sure it was
fully out yeah you didn't have you
weren't built to smoke you didn't have
that people that smoke and kids you
really shouldn't do it but they they
they sort of so cool about it they know
what they're doing it sounds like you
might was so calculated and full of
efforts that and when I finally did gain
the confidence after two days to go on
the like streets and do it
I can't it's like holding a matchbook
with a match and a cigarette in my hand
I just dropping the matchbook once I did
I singed my sleeve
oh that's the whole thing's a disaster
the whole thing was terrible and yeah
and I was smoking Marlboros - that's so
tough
yeah Marlboros like that's a Cowboys I
know it was bad but then after four days
I did think oh I'm getting cancer so I
stopped I'm glad you stopped
yeah allegedly those people have a lot
of money it was cowardly Thanks so you
I'm curious about something you did you
when you did you travel out in the city
what was it like because I'm trying to
you just imagine you on a subway you
just seem like you Ellie Kemper on a
subway would be a kind of a funny
experience yeah first time maybe yeah
that's um again I I think that's a
compliment cuz the subway is like a
dirty messy thing and I'm so pristine
yeah I would stare at people on you know
just taking it all in and I quickly
realized you can't stare people that
long and I and I gave myself like a time
limit I thought well you can't really
stare people for more than four seconds
but then when I was talking to your
segment producer about that not staring
someone for more than four seconds that
is such a long time to stare at someone
yeah it is you like like right now this
is a long time yeah yeah that's too long
and I just fell in love with you
you
you